the secretary of health and human
services tom price is with us this
morning and he declared a public health
emergency in response to harvey the
department sent an extra 53 000 pounds
of medical equipment and supplies to the
affected area it has more than 500
people on the ground helping those in
need secretary tom price joins us from
fema headquarters in washington d.c
secretary good morning good morning
laura what does this declaration do in
terms of being able to get the right
kind of medical and health treatment to
those here in houston
the declaration is incredibly important
because it allows us the flexibility to
respond when the local city county and
state officials need assistance so
whether it's in assisting transporting
patients whether it's in making certain
we have the pharmaceutical caches that
are necessary to restock the the
pharmacies in the area all the kinds of
things that make it so that we can
attend to the health and well-being of
individuals in this incredibly historic
disaster catastrophic disaster that
we're seeing right now
harris county's public hospital had to
evacuate shut down a lot of the evacuees
that came in here that i talked to last
night one of their concerns was i didn't
have time to get my diabetes medicine
how do you address those health concerns
yeah they're addressed locally initially
uh and and there are uh they're about uh
a number of pharmacies that are closed
but there are over 2000 pharmacies in
the area that are indeed open and the
vast majority of those continue to have
power uh so if it's a chain pharmacy
then those individuals are ought to be
working through through the uh the chain
uh otherwise they'll be contacting the
local in local officials the emergency
officials there if they're not able to
get their medication this is incredibly
important for people to be able to have
access to the kind of medication that
that that they need and and to try to
increase the
uh the cachet that they have on hand so
that they're able to weather the storm
secretary i'm here in houston but my
colleagues are up in new york and i'm
going to bring in margaret brennan here
i know has a question for you margaret
thanks norah
mr secretary would you urge congress
when they come back not to cut funds to
fema and to actually look at boosting
emergency funding
well thanks so much we continue to be in
the rescue phase the life-saving phase
of this uh i think that uh the the sense
of congress when they return will be to
focus their attention on this obviously
uh but right now we're concentrated on
the individuals on the ground there
there continue to be folks that that
that need to be saved that need to be
assisted in their health needs and their
and their human services needs and
that's where we're focused right now the
good news is that we pre-deployed
through health and human services more
individuals prior to this disaster than
ever in the history of hhs that means
that we're ready and able to be able to
respond to the needs based upon what the
local city county and state officials
need
okay health and human services secretary
tom price thank you very much this
morning for watching thank you